Speaker 1: Well, unfortunately, it's looking
like the 4th of July federal holiday here in the
United States is an increasingly dangerous day.
It's sort of beyond the scope of today's show
to give you the details of every mass shooting
and incident of gun violence that took place over
the 4th of July weekend. Hint there were about 13
or 14 different mass shootings over the weekend.
But I want to talk about the reaction, the
increasingly. I mean, it's an absurd reaction that
exists in the United States to these incidents.
Again, the focus from the American right wing is
on everything other than the tools with which
the shootings themselves are carried out,
the guns. And it's now not only about doors, it's
about ladders, it's about rooftops, it's about
alleys, unsecured alleys. And I will explain
it all, but in very rough strokes, another two.
I mean, listen, there were multiple mass shootings
yesterday. The two that made the most headlines
include one in the swanky Chicago suburb of
Highland Park, which took place during a 4th of
July parade where the shooter used a ladder to get
to a rooftop. The shooter was eventually captured
by police and taken into custody alive. Then there
was another incident where as of this moment,
it appears that two police officers at
minimum were shot during a fireworks event
in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. And immediately
we see the focus go to things that don't really
make any sense in Highland Park. Well, it
well, let's go backwards. In Uvalde, Texas,
the problem was there were too many doors
at the school. The doors were the problem.
And Ted Cruz and others saying reduce the
number of doors, secure the doors, etc..
In Highland Park, Illinois, the shooter used a
ladder to get to a rooftop. So the problem is,
well, you can't just leave random ladders around
where anybody could get to a rooftop. Too many
rooftops in the city, that's a problem. Unsecured
rooftops. And I put out a few tweets about this,
which many of you which seemed to resonate
with many of you. And they were sort of tongue
in cheek. The first one was Doors clearly are
not a solution for mass shootings like today's.
So what is the next proposal from Republicans to
avoid dealing with the guns? And in the replies,
it's filled with people saying, well, they're
going to talk about rooftops and ladders and all
of these things. And they did. I then tweeted,
Well, ban rooftops. Buildings should only have
a bottom, not a top. Of course, that's absurd.
But these are the types of reactions that we're
seeing. Maybe ban parades, maybe we have to harden
the parade routes almost as if it's the you know,
when there's a presidential inauguration, they
harden the route that the presidential motorcade
will take. Maybe every random parade now needs
that. Maybe ladders should be registered. No
age limit to buy a ladder, but certainly we need a
national registry of everybody that bans ladders.
What of? What I'm saying is a joke. I don't even
know at this point. I don't even know because
they want to deal with everything other than
the firearms. The police commander who is this
is the deputy chief of Lake County Sheriff's
Department, Christopher Covelli, was asked.
How did the shooter get to the
roof? Well, it wasn't secured.
Check the cell. Yeah. How he get out?
Speaker 2: So the roof was a business and
it looks like access to the roof via a ladder in
an alley was unsecure. Right. The whole matter of
a ladder that's attached to the building.
Speaker 1: Guys. There's all these ladders.
Sometimes they're fire escape ladders. They're
all over the place. They're completely unsecured,
obviously, because people need those. If there's a
fire, they've got to get out. Well, do we ban the
ladders or do we register the fire escapes or do
we lock them well? But then how do people escape?
Well, but then there's elevators. Maybe the
elevators need to be banned or secured or. Well.
Oh, no, but if the elevator. Then there's
the internal staircases in the building.
We've got to harden all ladders, elevators,
staircases and rooftops. Well, maybe that's
not the solution. Maybe instead, we just need
bulletproof vests at all parades, because, listen,
they're going to get up onto the roof. They
might have a gun or they might have a they might
have a machete, which they could throw from the
rooftop. So you've got to wear a bulletproof vest
when you go to a parade. That's the solution now.
And unfortunately, some of them seem to now be
accepting that we're just going to have these
types of events. But it's okay because we're
going to we need to have the guns. J.R. Maju Ski,
the Trumpian US House candidate who I interviewed,
he posted yesterday, I don't care if countries
in Europe have less fruit, by the way,
it should be fewer shootings. But that I'm reading
it as written. I don't care if countries in Europe
have less shootings because they don't have
guns. I care about the United States of America
and our Second Amendment rights. I think Americans
stopped caring what Europe thought of our country
in 1776. He's straight up saying it is more
important to have guns than to not have mass
shootings. Ted Cruz immediately sending prayers.
Ted and Heidi, they sent prayers. And to that,
I asked on Twitter, we've had another mass
shooting. Someone didn't pray hard enough or
correctly or to the right deity. Who was it? What,
guys? Prayer. That's how we stop this. I'm looking
at you. Which one of you didn't pray correctly?
Or to the right God? Or on the right day or enough
times per month? One of you is responsible because
you did faulty prayer. Come on, guys. We. How do
we win this when half the country. Well, maybe not
half when a significant portion of the country,
including many of the moneyed interests that
influence gun policy, are just accepting. We will
send prayers, but we won't do anything about guns.
Okay. We'd rather not have mass shootings, but
if we have to have them in order to keep our guns,
it's acceptable. How can we possibly deal with
this issue when that's the case? One guy who is
basically ready to throw in the towel personally
and I sympathize with him, is the mayor of
Philadelphia. And I want to talk about that next